all might is back baby and he is facing
off against Prime all for one all for
one is currently at full power and
stronger than ever before so is all
might about to make the ultimate
sacrifice just to buy the heroes
sometime is all for one about to kill
our boy all might also Dobby is about to
go supernova and kill a whole bunch of
Heroes and civilians and the only one
who can stop him is his brother Shoto
this is Peak mha we are truly reaching
the climax of The Story So let's get
into it you guys know the deal leave a
quick like and comment right now to help
me with that YouTube algorithm and if
you are one of the over 50 of people who
watch my videos regularly but haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
huge favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and also hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications finally this video will
contain mha manga spoilers so so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned in the previous chapter all for
one cleared the gunga Mountain
Battlefield after bodying everyone there
including the heroes hero students and
even his own former Lackey gigantomakia
although he was just one man going up
against all of these opponents he came
out on top because he is now young again
and this is allowing him to tap into the
full potential of every single one of
his quirks Prime all for one is an
absolute Menace and no one is able to
stop him to make things worse all for
one managed to steal hox's Quirk and
then took off flying in the direction of
shigaraki In This Moment all for one
seems Unstoppable and his reunion with
shigaraki seems inevitable I mean it's
not like the greatest Nemesis that he
has ever had in his entire life is about
to make a big return in order to stop
him right right well actually that is
exactly what happens but let's start
from the beginning the latest chapter
starts off with tsukan and the other
policemen at the police HQ straight up
panicking over what's currently
happening on the battlefield all for one
just flew over Edo City meaning that he
is moving extremely fast he is like
breaking the sound barrier he's just
zooming the cops have to find a way to
stop him somehow but they are simply
understaffed and outmatched they asked
for backup from every Hero on every
battlefield but everyone is already out
of commission as things stand all for
one has a clear path to shigaraki and
that's only the beginning of their
problems with all the attention that the
battle against all for one has been
getting we haven't seen Dobby in a while
but now we learn that the heat that's
coming from his flames in gunga is
absolutely overwhelming Endeavor is
still there fighting him but the thermal
energy that Dobby has been compressing
inside his body has reached such an
insane temperature that he could
literally explode at any moment if Dobby
continues like this he will only live
for another 10 minutes or so and then he
will go supernova all that massive
thermal energy that he has stored within
him will be released suddenly his body
will explode and the explosion will be
so massive that it will destroy
everything within a five kilometer
radius that is a 3.1 mile radius for all
our American friends worse yet La Brava
warns tsukauchi that some of the
civilians from the UA shelters are
within a five kilometer radius of
Dobby's current location meaning that
they will likely be killed if Dobby does
indeed explode we know from last chapter
that the shelter is already in a bad
State due to the sabotage from the spies
the ceiling is literally collapsing and
the lives of all of those people are in
serious danger including the lives of
the Todoroki family there's just no way
that this damaged shelter can withstand
the force of Dobby's blast in fact the
shelter may not even last the 10 minutes
before the explosion is supposed to
happen the people inside the shelter
will have to use the emergency exit and
emerge above ground and while this will
protect them from the ceiling collapsing
on their heads it will also make them
even more vulnerable to the effects of
the imminent explosion coming from Dobby
as for all for one he is now flying even
faster than before and he is almost
close enough to shigaraki to use that
warping Quirk that belonged to our boy
Johnny the normal rest in peace Johnny
gone but not forgotten long story short
all for one might reach shigaraki at any
moment and no hero can arrive in time to
stop him although realistically even if
they did arrive they probably wouldn't
be able to do much to Prime all for one
the best they can do now is try to slow
him down a bit and hope that his time
runs out as all for one has gotten
younger and younger he's gotten stronger
but he's also been more emotionally
unstable cruel and hateful anyone who
tries to get in his way now is basically
forfeiting their life the current
situation seems quite hopeless and poor
tsukauchi looks extremely stressed out
and desperate but then he hears a voice
calling out to him from the comms device
back in kamino Eda is helping an injured
Shoto and he tells Shoto that he still
hasn't recovered from using phosphor
against Dobby but Shoto assures him that
he's fine they can't stop now especially
since all for one could reach Deku at
any moment Ida wonders how Shoto is
dealing with the whole Dobby situation
since that has to be incredibly
traumatic for him but Shoto isn't
dwelling on it he's determined to help
stop all for one from reaching Deku and
shigaraki which would be everyone's
worst case scenario then they both hear
a voice coming from the comms device and
that voice belongs to almight he says
that he's happy to hear that the two of
them are doing okay and then he tells
them that they must get to goonga as
soon as possible almight tells them
about Dobby's situation and he explains
that they have to save the civilians
from the shelter but before Dobby's
explosion goes off and consumes them all
Shoto would still rather try and stop
over one because letting All For One
reach his intended target is so
dangerous but Almighty tells him not to
worry about that a powerful Ally is
already waiting to face off against all
for one the main thing that Shoto has to
do now is stop Toya's deadly Rampage and
reassure everyone that everything is
going to be okay all might believes that
Shoto and eda's quirks are essential for
saving everyone at goonga and so they
have to get there as soon as possible
shotus work is probably essential
because the ice side of his Quirk could
potentially cool Dobby down enough to
avoid an explosion altogether or
alternatively it may be able to create a
massive wall of ice that can stop the
explosion from reaching the civilians at
the shelter also we know that shoto's
new technique phosphor has the ability
to use cold fire to extinguish even the
hottest Flames which we know he already
demonstrated against Dobby with the move
called great glacial Ager so if you ask
me this aspect of phosphor will likely
prove to be crucial in stopping Dobby as
for eda's Quirk he will be essential for
getting Shoto to gungah on time and also
if Dobby really does end up exploding
Ida could potentially use his Quirk to
move Dobby away from the civilians
before he goes off however if Ida's
ultimate task ends up being the act of
moving Dobby out of range of the
civilians it is likely that Eda himself
will sacrifice his life in the process
in order to move Dobby away he will have
to carry him there and that means that
he will be right there next to Dobby
when he explodes anyway despite being
banged up and exhausted Eda puts Shoto
on his back and tells him to hold on
tight as all of this is happening stain
is still watching from above and he says
to himself that these people are true
altruistic Heroes either and Shoto then
take off at amazing speed literally
leaping from one building to another as
they Zoom from kamino to gunga this is
Ida's maximum speed and it is absolutely
incredible we've never seen Eda uses
Quirk at this level before it is
absolutely wild I know that Eda can't
keep this pace up forever but seeing how
insanely fast he is right now makes me
think that as a team he and Shoto May
really have a chance of stopping Dobby
what do you guys think will they succeed
in stopping Dobby will Eda have to
sacrifice his life to move Dobby out of
range of the civilians let me know down
below so a Shoto and Ida Rush towards
gunga we see all might standing beside
his car his Batmobile and waiting for
his greatest adversary to arrive that
powerful Ally who is waiting for all for
one is of course all might himself
tukauchi tries to tell almight that he's
being an idiot and that he has to get
out of there because he is quirkless but
almight says that this has always been
his bad battle all mine remembers when
Deku asked him whether he could be a
hero even without a quirk and he
remembers that he too started his life
quirkless just like Deku now is the time
for almight to prove to Deku and to
himself that you can be a hero without a
quirk now of course all for one would be
better off if he just ignored all might
and remained focused on his main goal of
reaching shigaraki but all my
discounting on the Intel he received
from Hawks Intel that states that the
younger all for one has less control of
his negative emotions than his older
self and that he is filled with the kind
of hatred that the older called and
calculating all for one just didn't have
this means that when all for one sees
all might he won't be able to resist the
challenge he won't just keep flying
towards shigaraki he will stay and fight
his Nemesis the man who defeated him
twice and on whom all for one wants to
exact his revenge and that is exactly
what all might is hoping for all for one
then sees all might from the air and he
immediately Smiles maniacally and
prepares to confront his Nemesis but
almight is prepared suddenly his
briefcase and his car begin to transform
as if they are about to turn into some
overpowered high-tech armor it seems
that all might is about to face all for
one not with the power of quirks but
with the power of the latest modern
technology Weaponry Weaponry that was
probably created by the Elon Musk of mha
principal nezu as we see all might's
iconic line I am here written across the
page this chapter comes to an end and
first and foremost I have to say that
this was a fantastic chapter that built
up a ton of tension with both Dobby and
all for one and we got the heroic return
of all might clearly almight has a plan
and he has a secret weapon in the form
of a crazy high-tech armor now future
heuristic technology has always been a
part of the mha world it's good to think
of it as a world that is significantly
ahead of our own technologically
although it's not clear just how far
into the future we're talking about
because it is an alternate world but
because the focus of the series has
always been on quirks and Quirk combat
modern technology has always been just
there in the background like yeah we've
seen the floating UA and the fancy
shelters but the battles are still
conducted with the use of quirks not
modern Weaponry well that seems to be
changing as all might looks like he's
turning himself into a Gundam pilot it
looks like we're about to see him put on
some sort of advanced exoskeleton armor
that will presumably allow him to fight
all for one this battle suit might even
be a direct reference to Iron Man
because I think I remember Iron Man
having a suitcase that transforms into
his armor in one of the Marvel movies as
we know horikoshi loves referencing
Western comic franchises almost as much
as he loves referencing Star Wars so
it's no surprise that we're getting some
Iron Man right now but do I think that
modern tech alone will be enough to stop
all for one I believe all might may be
able to buy some time but in the end all
for one will wreck him I mean if over
one destroyed gigantomakia then he will
not lose to gundam almight as much as
we'd like to see all might make an epic
comeback after losing his work and that
is why this climactic return of all
might to the story feels both like a
really exciting and long-awaited moment
and a really scary moment because it
really feels like a major death flag I
mean just look at all mine's face
throughout this chapter and how he talks
to everyone it really feels like he is
preparing to make the final sacrifice
right here and now it feels like he is
about to sacrifice his life to buy some
time for the heroes in this desperate
moment we've all been speculating for a
long time about the ultimate fate of all
might in the series and his death has
always been a possibility because he's
already passed the torch to a new
generation and being the legendary hero
that he is is going out in a blaze of
heroic Glory would be a fitting end to
his life an end that would also raise
the stakes in the story and have a
massive impact on deku's character
development I can totally see all my
dying in this fight but his sacrifice
will not be in vain because I'm sure
that he will play an important role in
stopping all for one from executing his
master plan fun fact but if you don't
know yet I recently made a video in
which I talked about how all might dying
earlier on in the series could have
resulted in Deku turning to the dark
side and becoming an actual villain no
joke that is probably my favorite video
that I've ever made so please do me a
big favor and check it out Link in the
description and in the pinned comment
but although I think that current
almight plus modern technology will not
be even close to enough for defeating
all for one there's been a lot of
speculation out there about all might
potentially using Aries Quirk to rewind
himself back to his prime just like all
for one was able to do that would allow
Primal might to face off against Prime
I'm all for one in an absolutely epic
Clash of Good and Evil and this could
also end in all might making the
ultimate sacrifice as he rewinds himself
out of existence just like all for one
unless Arie figures out a way to rewind
all might without killing him after all
all might has the advantage of Arie
actually liking him and wanting to help
him whereas all for one just had to make
do with fragments of her Quirk because
she would never cooperate with him
willingly so who knows all might could
definitely die here this could be his
last stand and final sacrifice but we
could also see some Shenanigans
involving Arie and her Quirk what do you
guys think is all might about to die
will he use rewind to go back to his
prime or will he try to fight with just
modern technology will he succeed in
delaying all for one long enough for the
villain to rewind himself out of
existence or will he fail in this task
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below and also don't
forget to check out my video on what if
Deku became a villain Link in the
description and on screen if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more in
the future leave a quick like right now
and if you're one of the over 50 of
people who watch my videos regularly but
you still haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications